okay
for people joining this live stream this
is uh
talking about wolfram language design
specifically
submitting batch external jobs
boy i could have used this just last
night i probably should have done
um okay
so let's get some some kind of uh
okay so batch submit
as opposed to remote i mean
how does batch submit can we imagine
batch submit working on a local machine
at some point
uh not not usefully
um if the only the only um
embedding of that that makes sense is
the kubernetes idea uh having that
summit work with the kubernetes
cluster but where it's a one machine
cluster and the only machine is your
local machine
and i mean it would work but it would it
would not be substantially different
um uh from uh from working on a
remote uh oh just
get get me a sense of this because you
know i'm routinely using
you know on my machines i'm routinely
saying
let me give you a workflow thing so i
say
you know um
whatever it is parallel evaluate process
id or something i've got lots of
parallel
kernels right but what i do
normally is i just say you know parallel
table
or something like this and then i've
blocked my master kernel
right something so do i have any choice
about that
in using parallel uh submission
or parallel evaluate uh i mean that's a
question for roman but i don't think so
roman i mean if i said like
local submit of parallel evaluate would
that work
i don't i don't think so since local
submit runs in a sub kernel and some
kernels can't launch other sub criminals
a drum in here he is
roman
i thought roman was there he might be
having trouble with this audio i'll
check on him
okay he says he's here
so um okay but so
is there any okay well why can't a sub
kind of launch
kernels well that's definitely a
question for roman
okay but i mean this use case
is the one that i'm interested in that
is the batch submission you know it's
like
i've got lots of local machines i want
to just submit something i mean how
what's the best way to have this work on
on
local machines it's the kubernetes route
which is
which would be a kubernetes remote
submission provider for batch submit or
batch submission provider whatever you
decide to call it
um but that would then be able to have a
bunch
of sub kernels that could support
parallelism is that right
uh not sub kernels full kernels that
support parallel
uh sub kernels or um if
it would it would work best uh using
using uh uh what was called remote map
submit which now will probably be called
batch map submit um which creates
multiple jobs it chunks up an input list
uh it's it's like map or parallel map
but it chunks up the input list
and creates a job for each chunk and
then within each job it uses
math or parallel map to evaluate over
that
uh you know okay here's my naming issue
i really feel i know it's long but i
really feel that this should be remote
batch submit
because it's really one of the remote
family of functions
so i'm saying i mean in other words
somebody says what can i do on a remote
machine oh you've got remote this we've
got
remote evaluate you've got remote
whatever this fits with those
can you hear me now well you're a bit
faint roman
okay let me try no no now you're better
now you're sounding more assertive and
you're better
now there's sometimes there's a problem
that even though
volume should be up there is absolutely
zero
so i'm sorry that that happened at the
worst possible time
so now in terms of submitting parallel
jobs i mean all the local the local
submission within the same
thread of the same master kernel doesn't
work what
does work is submitting individual
parallel jobs rather than using
something like parallel map
and so that the uh
there's a parallel submit and wait next
uh paradigm which which does not tie up
the the master kernel
does it actually does it start
evaluating when you do parallel submit
or only when you do the wing no you need
you need to there's no background
scheduler that's something that is
probably now doable but
at the time that is a very non
mim that output blob is very weird
looking for modern times
and it's quite beautiful but it's very
weird so what do i do to to actually get
this thing run
okay so yes you you
you say weight all of percent
okay but so what what is it doing right
now i mean what
what did it it it didn't
i mean it does it does when you it does
submit
the first job and then but
when these the first generation of jobs
are done on the parallel kernels
you have to you have to trigger another
one through the through the service loop
so
typically of course you would you would
submit a whole bunch of these
and then you have two choices
wait all as you have done here which
blocks until everything is done or wait
next which just
blocks until the first job returns
then you can decide whether you want to
continue or to abandon the
rest of it okay let me tell you the
workflow that i want okay
so my very typical workflow is i'm
running interactively i want to do a big
computation which i would otherwise
leave running overnight
okay or so what i will often do is i
will create
a different local kernel and i will run
it in some notebook that's connected to
a different local kernel and then i'll
run it
with parallel kernels connected to that
different local kernel
but what i would like to do is somehow
just
launch that big computation and forget
about it
and wait for it to notify me that it's
done
okay yeah that that's more like a
submission parallel yes i mean batch
submit
of parallel something right right i
think something important to establish
is that there's no cur there's no
paradigm current paradigm of
parallel computation using the parallel
x functions that lets you
um uh submit something that runs uh
disconnected from the master kernel that
master kernel has to stay running if
it dies then then you've lost your
connections to the subject which is
probably just as well i mean i have
these
weird programs to kill rogue kernels
because they sometimes go rogue when the
master kernel dies
the sub-kernels don't die yes i mean
they
they need to read or try to read or
write to their parent link to
to notice that it's gone away and so if
they are in a tight loop
then there's no way they would notice
that they should die
right they probably should have some
tools at least in the function
repository
for killing rogue kernels yes i mean the
one way to do it is to use the more
modern
versions of ssh which and to keep to
keep the connection open
at the moment the ssh is only used to
launch the kernel and then
everything goes through the mouselink
connection but
in the future we could could leave the
ssh connection open
and then to kill the kernel you would
simply
terminate that connection and that would
then kill
could kill all the processes on the
remote sounds like a good idea to me
yeah so okay stephen for your workflow
it sounds like what you need is is
something like remote submit
where you know you you basically calling
remote evaluate
that remote kernel is the master kernel
for the parallel computation
and you just don't want to wait until it
finishes so you need a remote evaluate
that is asynchronous and that would be
remote submit presumably
do we have remote submit well that's
what this was called no but we don't we
don't have
um the thing that i just mentioned this
sort of you know
no no batch logic nothing like that just
just the analog
it's just remote evaluate done
asynchronously
now okay let's go ahead
i i want to mention that remote submit
slash batch submit or
whatever we call it is topologically
similar to that in that it is relying on
something else that is not the master
kernel to be keeping track of these
uh of the one or multiple uh jobs that
have been launched
uh and in the case of aws facts that
thing is the aws batch job scheduler
which is provided by aws
charity engine charity engines job
scheduler and it is kubernetes
the kubernetes scheduler so it's it's
it's it's the the thing that is that is
doing the book
bookkeeping and keeping track of of of
what's running is uh is disconnected is
not dependent on the
the existence of the master kernel okay
every time you submit something what
there must be some agent that
takes care of the asynchronous and
allows you to
to collect results or job statements yes
exactly and that that agent is provided
by
amazon or provided by charity engine or
it is kubernetes okay so let me ask this
question
about task objects okay and what comes
back and whether it's a task object or
whether it's something different do task
objects survive
across sessions actually brian our live
stream is asking
for sort of clarity on on um
uh you know what different kinds of
things come back
so right now if i do
a cloud submit
what's going to happen here okay that
comes back as a task object
and now that task object does or does
not survive the termination of the
session
it does not okay does any task object
survive the termination of the session
um i haven't haven't really been able to
figure this out it seems that it's uh
only if it is a cloud scheduled task
so for example if i would say cloud
submit of scheduled tasks
yes which i should note scheduled tasks
do not apply that's
not relevant in the batch submit world
just for
just to establish that no i that i
understand that it's not scheduled back
batches just do it as soon as you can
um okay so if i were to do this
and schedule a task
then that would create a persistent task
object is that true
um define persistence it will cr it will
return an expression
that can be used in subsequent sessions
that that
the input form of that expression but it
doesn't persist
in any way on the uh on on the client
side beyond the termination of your
your session and handler functions
of course will get disconnected when you
terminate the session so wait a minute
so so
but the scheduled task will keep doing
its thing
yes in the cloud and the
i think the only if you if you submit
that and then terminate your local
session and you keep that expression
around and try to do something with it
later i think the only things you can do
with that are
stuff like stopping it and or pausing it
and resuming it
it has some handle but the scheduled
task is ultimately a cloud object is
that true
yes
i mean what's the difference between
cloud submit of a scheduled task and
cloud deploy of a scheduled task
i have no i i suspect cloud deploy the
scheduled task doesn't work
but i don't know for sure i think it
does okay
it's possible um
you're right look what we've got is two
different things here
we've got things that have a persistent
handle that are tasks
independent of where they were started
and we've got things
that are you know connected to their
starter
yes on the on the task object side it's
only a very limited class of tasks that
can be persistent
uh that persists across sessions that is
cloud scheduled tasks
because i i mean okay one shot
cloud tasks the task object
can exist in a new session but from what
i've found
you can't do anything useful with it
because you can't query output from it
and then
this is a mess i mean listen the budget
problem is
cloud deploy of a scheduled task gives a
cloud object
cloud submit of a scheduled task
probably gives a task object it does
that in fact has some persistent
character to it
persistent in not the task object itself
does not have any persistence i know
that but it has a backing a piece of
backing that is persistent
all that is is the cloud object it
points i know that i know i mean so
what we've got here cloud objects are
persistent things just like your amazon
you know whatever that object is that
aws is created in the aws
cloud effectively is a persistent flag
associated with um
um
right with with these um
look there's a confusion here okay
because
right now okay
what is the way that you would do a a
batch type job submitted to our cloud
it's cloud submit isn't it
yes but there's but there's a very
crucial point there which is that you
cannot query the output after
after you end your current session it
cannot be done okay so
that's kind of crazy i mean but because
it doesn't have a persistent thing
unlike a scheduled task which has a
persistent cloud object associated with
it
that allows you to ask questions about
the scheduled task a cloud submit
job does not have a persistent cloud
object associated with no it does have a
persistent cloud object associated with
it you just can't query its output i
don't know why you just can't
what does that mean yeah i mean it see
it seems that since the cloud
is persistent there should be a function
to query to list
all existing task objects and then you
could there is
there is except it gives you a cloud
object not a task object you can do
you can do tasks of the string cloud
oh gosh that's horrifying
okay how do i find out anything about
these things
uh the only way i know is is to click on
it i don't think you can you can
re you can create a task object for me
what
what's gonna happen if i click on it
there's some dashboard uh thing yeah you
gotta you got a dashboard page
wow that's cool it's pretty it says that
what is this well so this page is nice
and how does this page
relate to the page that you would get in
aws
um it's not it's not really the same
because this isn't
this is intended to communicate
information about scheduled tasks even
if it's a one-shot
task it shows it as a scheduled task
that only runs once
um but i mean there is a corresponding
page in aws that you can see for a
so this is very interesting i mean this
is
this is what i mean i i honestly i knew
we were building this at some point i
don't think i've ever looked at it um
my understanding is that it is expressly
for managing scheduled tasks
it is no utility for a one-shot task
except possibly viewing the law
i think there's some way to view uh log
output in there
but in principle
a batch job were you to have a batch job
in our cloud
or in a private cloud you could imagine
a description of what's going on that
looks like this
yes i could imagine that okay
all right okay let's start looking at
remote batch submit
um okay but can we look at the names can
we look at the
the universe of names related to batch
submit
and see what they all look like with
this new naming convention
right so this was this was the proposal
my proposal and you can tweak that
as you as you like
okay so i think it should be remote
batch
remote batch submit now remind me what
map submit does uh that's that's
analogous to parallel map
you give it a function and you give it a
list and it creates it chunks
behind the scenes it chunks up that list
into jobs uh
and submits a job for each chunk if you
open up the demo section at the bottom
you can see
just an example of what that looks like
uh but it the advantage of that over
remote submit there are
two main advantages one is that you can
run uh jobs
uh that uh that execute simultaneously
across multiple machines because you're
not limited to the number of cpus on one
machine
and also you can retrieve partial
results so if only some of the chunks
have completed you can retrieve those
results
and like check that they're right and
not insane uh before waiting you don't
have to wait for the whole
entire uh array job to finish
and this is probably what you what you
will be using for at least for your
larger
types of jobs that's my expectation
okay
that name hopefully will change as
appropriate
oh that's just that's just the name of
the specific job queue in our aws
account actually
that can have any name that you want
okay but i mean it should be a name that
okay so let's just try to understand
this by the question from ethan on our
live stream can remote submit
work with net train if so
how do you specify where the data is
coming from
and how do you monitor the training uh
that's a great question it does work
with net train and it works very well
because you can create
ec2 instances that you use attached to
them uh you would uh your input data you
would specify it either just as an
expression that exists in your local
session and it will be picked up
automatically um because uh using
include definitions
semantics um so if you have a variable
data in your local session that you've
defined and you do remote submit of
something that does something with data
it will automatically
get uh bundle data up and and submit it
or
upload it along with the uh the job or
you can use an input file
um which is there's an input files
option to
uh remote submit back submit whatever it
ends up being called
uh that lets you specify files on your
local machine that again get
automatically uploaded alongside the job
um and and are accessible uh within the
jobs environment you can import them
and then on the uh monitoring uh what
about external storage why can't you use
an s3 external storage why can't can you
can you
directly connect to external storage you
cannot do it right now only because
there is not an
s3 external storage uh provider but i i
i
very much like coming soon right i know
but it doesn't exist right now so you
can't do it
okay but when you can do it the data
path if you
have an external storage reference in
your code you will
simply be able to um to give that
just like you could reference a local
file which will be pulled in
when when things are packaged up to be
sent to the remote
job running pro system if it's a local
file it will pick up the local file and
move it over there
but if it's external storage it will
know oh that's s3 external storage
i can just have a separate data path
that picks it up directly from s3
correct
yes there will be uh practically there
will be some limitations like you have
to use you will have to use an s3 bucket
that uh
that your uh your instance has
permissions to access
uh and you won't necessarily be able to
use other external storage providers
because there's no method like dropbox
there's no method for
yeah right tough luck i mean that's
right you gotta move your data to s3 and
then you can
use it in the aws environment right but
yes i i definitely hope for this to be
possible and another
advantage of it is that if you upload
input files using the normal
local file system method um you will
then be able to
obtain the external storage object that
that uh represents that
that in that previously uploaded input
file and use it again in a subsequent
job so you don't have to upload
uh yeah right well i assume most people
will have very large data sets
they've already put on s3 and then
they're they're using
this to do the plumbing to connect those
large existing data sets
into the actual computation system right
yes that's possible there are some
advantages of doing the upload using
um within remote submit um
really the advantage is that it you're
it's guaranteed that the permissions are
correct because it uploads the same
bucket that it
um that it uses to upload the job code
itself and
the permissions i think you got it okay
yes it will be
it will be possible and just to adjust
the uh the person's question about uh
monitoring progress
uh you can obtain um uh at least on aws
this isn't
this isn't i don't think this is the
case on charity engine at least not yet
but you can obtain the current log um
the current standard out
uh uh uh log from the kernel um
in well basically in real time you can
uh it's not automatically it's not
dynamic
uh you do it's the uh job log uh
property of a
of a remote job object or again whatever
it ends up being called
um and i think there is an example of
that under okay
but so so question is training progress
you know we have all those beautiful
training progress indicators
those won't work but there is a not
quite as beautiful beautiful but still
reasonable
um training progress indicator that you
see in a standalone kernel in
text only output and you'll be able to
see the uh the output from that by
accessing the job block
okay well there's a question about
dynamics i think dynamics are absolutely
hopeless
on about that's correct i mean because
they are they are a thing
of of real-time feedback loops which
run right they require the front end to
have a connection to the kernel
and that's not the case here um
okay question um a number of questions
here uh there's a question about
microsoft azure
i i believe that is being worked on is
that a true story
i'm yeah i'm uh i'm look i've i've
looked into it and
uh azure has a um a service that's
essentially an analog
of aws batch very very similar and
actually more powerful in some ways
um so i plan to create a uh a remote
submission provider
uh for for azure's uh batch service
so ethan here is is lamenting the fact
it's kind of well of course the kernel
does call the front end it is running a
front end
but there's no human seeing it i mean
this is uh well
it's only running a front end if you
launch a front hand
well if you need to launch your front
end right like if you want to do
notebook manipulation
but there's there's no there's no way to
to connect to or see that
right i mean i i don't know i i don't
understand what you would use dynamics
for in a batch setting
but maybe i'm just confused um well i
can i can understand the wanting
the uh the desire to see that like the
net train dynamic progress indicator
because it's true that that's very nice
and it's helpful
but i i just think that's not the world
of batch processing i mean
back in the day you would put your card
deck in a pigeon hole and somebody would
pick it up and
then you know stuff the print out in the
right yeah we don't have a punch card
external storage provider
no i understand that but i mean you know
the world of batch jobs is not a world
where you get to see things in real time
correct it's uh you know at best you see
a log file
because i have no idea whether these
things actually run quickly or not
i mean they might you know if if you say
i'm on the slow boat
you know then when you know i'm i'm i'm
wait listed for whatever
it might take a while for your batch job
to run and then your dynamic would look
rather silly
right well here here you manage the
environment that it's submitted to
so um so if you configure your
environment correctly and essentially
are willing to pay it will run
it will run immediately it only could
only get queued up behind something if
you
submit if you submit basically more jobs
than you have configured your
environment to
uh to run concurrently okay but i'm sure
there's a
a you know run this when it's cheap type
option and things
not really um there is
not not not particularly um it's
it is technically possible to do that
because uh you're using ec2 spot
instances but
it's um that is not a prices do not vary
that much that enough that it would be
useful wow
okay times have changed i mean actually
the prices the prices
using on-demand instances the prices are
fixed um
the prices only vary when you're using
spot instances which have
which give you a discount over on demand
uh but there are also
there are some downsides uh to using
spot instances
um that's interesting okay so listen
there are a bunch of comments here on
that live stream that are
quite interesting and i'd like to just
go through them and then we'll go back
to the um
so there's a question here about whether
um
whether this some remote map
submit does proper batching i would
assume it is i mean i assume it's doing
the same thing that parallel map is
doing
uh roughly the same thing it's the same
kind of thing
um if you uh scroll down on
in the demo there i think there's a
there there that job packing
actually that's not okay it's very ugly
can you
please i know you said that you said
that last time i will go through
design can you scroll up actually
there's an example of that one that's
uh that's better um under the uh items
for approval
uh and then the visualizations
job packing visualization right so so
the second one of those
um the the way that remote map submit
works is it creates what's called an
array job which is just a container that
can contain
multiple child jobs within it um and it
the red square in there represents a
single evaluation so if you have a list
of 50 items each
uh each item is one evaluation of your
function
uh applied to that uh to that item um so
it splits up
uh your list of 50 items into in this
case six
child jobs of seven evaluations each and
one child job with eight evaluations
um so it attempts at least by default
you can configure this but it attempts
to
uh to um uh to shape it into basically a
square
uh where like rows are are um are
appropriately presumably it depends on
how long each job takes and things
no it does because it doesn't know this
is done this is done at
uh uh at when when you evaluate remote
map submit it
it cannot reconfigure itself uh uh
subsequently depending on how long
things are taken
so how does this why is this not
resizable or is it resizable but it's
just why is this so slow to resize
it's crazy okay so how does this relate
to this kind of dashboard
how does one relate job what you're
saying
is that this is a so job packing
visualization is merely
for your information this is how the
jobs are packed but yeah i'm telling you
the id
numbers of jobs and things correct it's
not telling
yeah it's just a it is a it's uh it's a
useful visualization for understanding
what what remote maps
is doing with your uh with your job um
but this uh the dashboard that you're
showing
um i mean there isn't
what what does it actually show because
the because
if you want to see the machines you can
go to the ec2 dashboard in the
in the aws console um but that's not
that's not particularly useful except
for for debugging
um what what else does this dashboard
like stuff like cpu usage you can also
get that from
aws from cloud watch um
so one of the things we could imagine
doing is
having some utility
that will collect the necessary
information from aws
and display a thing like this for you
yes but it is
it's a little it's a little tricky to do
that because there can be multiple jobs
running on one
uh on one instance and if you have two
array jobs
it could be um like one child job for
one array job and one child dog from
another array
of running on the same instance and you
can only think you can only usefully get
cpu information at the
full instance level um uh so it would be
you
would you could perhaps you could you
could perhaps ask for a dashboard that
just shows your whole environment
without regard
for uh for what jobs are where um
uh but there i don't think there's any
useful way to provide uh
uh visualization of cpu utilization on
the um
on the individual job level okay fair
enough all right let's just quickly
go through these other things and then i
want to um
uh come back so there are various
comments here about basically if you've
got a piece of code and it runs locally
and then you say now i want to send it
out for batch
running and so on as seamless as we can
um
the you can for one thing you can you
can wrap any you can wrap remote submit
in
basically any chunk of code and it will
it will just it will
it will run it will run it remotely on a
single instance with
up to uh well up to in the case of aws
uh uh 96 vcpus um but you can configure
that of course
um the remote if it's a remote
job submit right can the remote job
submit i keep on maybe i'm keep on
asking the same question can the remote
job submit contain a parallel table
yes absolutely okay so it's just it just
is living on a 96 core machine
and whatever you would normally be able
to do on a 96 core machine you'll be
able to do correct
remote submit is a single job uh that
can have access to
uh to multiple uh vcpus
or what we're now calling remote batch
submit
right if yes if that's what we're
calling it i think it would be useful to
actually go over the names and decide
what they will be because i know but i i
want to understand the full
functionality and how it relates to the
functionality we don't have and so on as
well okay
sure um now there is there is a caveat
to the
um to having it just work which is that
for
for for maximum for maximum efficiency
it's always good to uh to build your
code from the ground up with the
uh idea of having it uh be parallelized
that's that's the case
existing parallelization functionality
and it is also the case here with
like with remote map submit that that
doesn't um
like you can you can convert a parallel
map into a remote map submit uh because
it's the same syntax
um but for example if you have multiple
maps in sequence those have to become
multiple jobs
um for example you can't nest um correct
yeah you can't nest i mean you can't
nest even in in the case of parallel
table you can't nest that either
um right but uh you know you could
clearly nest a parallel table inside
a um uh remote
batch map submit uh no you can't because
remote
remote batch map submit is uh is
um is launching uh you okay again you
can
you can always configure these things
but there is the case where remote batch
map submit is launching
say 10 jobs each of which have 16 vcpus
uh allocated to them
uh and it will be it will chunk up your
list of say 160
items into 10 chunks one goes to each
machine
um or one goes to each uh job sorry
which is actually a docker container
uh and then it it will use parallel map
inside that job to map your function
across that list of 16 items so it will
be using parallelization
it automatically parallelizes okay so
your comment about rewriting code and so
on i mean basically
you know look i use parallel stuff all
the time
and you know occasionally i do something
stupid where i haven't realized there's
just tons and tons of data to be sent
across the parallel links
and in fact it's a total lose and yes
things like that can happen
um let's just go through a couple of the
other
um uh okay so there's a question about
block map with block sizes chosen for
optimal
time memory threads yeah i mean that's
what this is trying to do
yes and you can configure it you can you
see there it says method goes to
automatic there are there are three
other
method uh uh parameters that are uh in
spot
influenced by the methods for parallel
combine which also apply to parallel
math and parallel table
um they're not exactly the same but
they're similar and they let you
basically change
effectively change what that
visualization looks like looks like
change
how it chunks let's let's just go
through quickly some of the other things
on the live stream then i want to come
back to
function naming and so on a question
from alexander here is there a task id
when running cloud submit and then the
cloud maintains the relationship between
the task id and the completion object id
right i mean that's that has to do with
this question about persistent tasks
which i think is a mess and i think we
should look at separately i mean i think
basically
if it's persistent it's a cloud object
if it's a task object it's somehow
ephemeral to that particular job but you
should probably be able to rehydrate a
task object
from a cloud object am i making sense
yes that sounds reasonable to me it's
just if you could do that
then we would solve the problem i mean
in other words then the task object
is specific you know to
to a particular master job so to speak
but then subsequently you just say task
object of a cloud object
where the cloud object is the persistent
uh
you know monument or something to the uh
the the task you submitted roman would
that
is that your thing or uh how would that
work
it's it's not roman's thing i don't
think who's whose thing is it todd is it
do you know how that would work i think
i think
constantine is currently responsible for
tasks okay so
why don't we find out whether that can
maybe carla can go track that down and
find out whether that can be made to
work
so in other words given that you in
other words the strategy is this
a task object is is local to a session
okay if it is going to be persistent it
is a cloud object
but you can wrap a task object around
that
to get task-like functionality in a new
session
based on your old your your pre-existing
uh sort of uh persistent
um cloud object i mean
what this is it's it reminds me very
much of the persistent value system
somehow i mean in other words it's a
persistent
job of a kind that we don't you know
that's a new kind of thing for us we
have persistent storage cloud objects of
that
this is a persistent job of some kind or
persistent task of some kind
does that make sense yeah i mean there
are various ways of
i mean one way the obvious way is to if
you submit something to a cloud then
the natural thing to use the cloud
object and you should be able to
get back a useful task object in a local
session but
for other cases where it's not the cloud
i mean you should be able to store
your task objects in in a local object
for example
that would survive uh a session we start
and then
the same way you should be able to get
back i'm not sure that the task object
is what you should
i don't think that's the right thing i
don't think the task object should be
the persistent object
can i can we clarify what exactly we're
talking about we're not talking about
remote batch jobs right or are we
no we're talking about things that you
that you do with local submit
session submit and maybe a future remote
submit that we don't have yet
right well local submit and session
submit uh obviously there's no
no it's impossible for for that to be
persistent because they're both
uh intimately linked to the uh to the
master kernel because local submit is in
the sub kernel
um session submit is in the master
funnel um uh running
uh preemptively um so cloud cloud submit
is the only existing
uh submission like x submit uh function
where it makes sense to have persistence
and that there is right now is not that
much resistance
right but i'm saying i'm saying what
persists is a cloud object
but then you can you know rehydrate that
cloud object in a subsequent session
to treat it as a task in a subsequent
session i think this requires separate
investigation but okay so i just want to
just want to go through some of these
other um let's see
uh swsh is suggesting kubernetes
p-a-a-s what is that platform as a
service i think
i'm i'm not they might be talking about
solutions yes well this this would work
after that because kubernetes is is
very much uh uh infrastructure
independent
if if everything is set up correctly
with
so this is saying kubernetes platform as
a service with wall from engines ready
with wall from engine ready workers on
them
um i uh are
is this in relation to i think this is
in relation to remote
uh uh that submit yes right this is your
proposal of a kubernetes
i think well yeah it's kubrick it's it's
remote remote uh
batch submit sorry i'm still still
wrapping my mouth around the
new name uh wrote back submit uh
to any kubernetes cluster whether it be
on your local network or
uh on on google cloud or or azure or aws
right but then then so then eventually
we would have
a thing that you download from
you know from us like you can download
wall from engines which will be a
kubernetes a container
that is the thing you need
to be able to run to be able to
be the server for a
remote batch submit to a kubernetes
cluster
right it's a little it's a little more
than that it's the the container is one
thing but then there's also the
configuration around it
um uh but yes that is uh that would be
packaged into um in kubernetes it's
called a chart that's the configuration
of
uh they use nautical terminology uh
configuration of
um uh of uh multiple services how could
they not use nautical for
given that kubernetes comes from a a
helmsman right in greek right yeah they
use they use nautical terminology for
everything
um okay uh
[Music]
let's see um
okay so the comment here was with the
kubernetes platform as a service
sw is saying one can mount persistent
volumes from whatever provider
that is supported by kubernetes plugins
yes uh persistence while
persistent volumes are actually very
important for uh remote uh
remote batch submit uh because it has to
have somewhere to store input and output
files uh from jobs and those output
files need to
still be accessible after the job uh has
finished so having having persistent
volumes uh that are accessible
uh across uh machines uh is is an
important
thing to have right so as we were saying
wouldn't it be great to rent hourly
clusters
from from us i mean basically we
we're not in the business of providing
sort of as large scale things as
something like obvious or
zero we you know our cloud and by the
way those comments about scheduled tasks
only running
granularities of an hour that's because
that's necessary for our
uh scheduling purposes in our cloud um
if you have a an enterprise private
cloud an instance of our cloud
then that restriction is no longer
present that's just something
i think i may be wrong about this but i
think if you have a paid
certain levels of paid plan you can have
scheduled tasks that run more frequently
yeah it could be um i mean but the
problem is that we have to limit that
because we don't have
you know we don't have infinite
infrastructure so to speak
yeah with with remote batch submit we're
providing you the
the you get the choice of cloud provider
and you manage your
uh infrastructure uh on that provider
you decide right i mean
whether eventually we will be able to do
this through our own
credit system and whether you'll be able
to just have an account with us i'm not
sure
um that's i think more or less a detail
um okay there's a there's a question
here
about remote submit with a money
constraint
um is that
how does that work yeah that's a very
interesting idea and it makes it makes
sense
it's just um depending on the provider
it may be more or less difficult on aws
it's more difficult because um aws
is essentially choosing the instance
types that it launches to satisfy your
jobs
based on your job's requirements you can
set constraints on that like only use
this
instance type um but by default it makes
the most sense for to allow aws to make
these choices
i will choose it will choose instance
types uh depending on
on your jobs um now it is possible to
calculate how
uh roughly how much a given job uh
will will cost um uh beforehand in fact
they have a
a form for that that's a little how can
you do that i mean you're running a
random turing machine you don't know if
it holds oh and i'm
based on knowing how long uh or
estimates on how long your
uh your job will take i see okay fair
enough and
i see so how much wall clock time it
will take given that you know how much
cpu time it's taking or something right
exactly and depending on how you want to
uh you
how you more about our
engine what's the memory footprint of
our engine it's quite small isn't it
um yeah what i've found is that uh
parallel
i don't know that much about this but
what i found just in my experimentation
is that parallel sub kernels each
require
around uh 200 megabytes absolute minimum
uh to like to
to start and not substitute in the
modern world
yeah i think so uh and depending on what
you're doing obviously the memory
memory footprint uh will increase i
actually i have remote
uh batch remote batch submit configured
um uh when you're using aws you can
again you can change these options but
by default it will
it will allocate i think it's uh about
two gig
uh two gigabytes or two gigabytes rather
of memory uh per cpu per vcpu
um and you can you can change that but
that's uh
that's that's it's a reasonable minimum
so your your
sub kernels don't spontaneously die
because that happens if you don't give
them enough memory
um okay let's um
let's take a look now at uh at all these
detailed names and things
okay so let's look at uh
okay so what we're talking about i mean
this thing remote batch
map submit boy that's pretty ugly as a
name
i mean why do you want the word remote
in there i mean isn't that
remote because we have other things like
batch applied which is a
i just feel like it's part of the remote
family because it's really not on our
infrastructure
you know things that don't have remote
are on our infrastructure just like the
word external
means it's not in our language basically
isn't batch submission always remote
it is implied but it's not it's true
that it's not really explicit
well okay so roman is claiming that we
could
just leave it as batch submit i don't
know i think that's going to be
confusing to people
i think they're going to think you can
do batch submission on your local
machine
which you cannot without lots of
additional infrastructure
that's true well now you'll see that
there's only a set of providers
to this you know there's a fixed set of
providers
charity and amazon at the moment and you
know
i still think it will be cleaner
conceptually i mean this is a you know
setting this up is a big complicated
thing typing an extra however many
six characters is not going to be the
main thing the question is the
conceptual clarity
um is it similar enough to other remote
i mean remote evaluate remote
with motorola well remote evaluate okay
so remote evaluate
takes a machine name right yes
okay
and we can imagine a remote submit that
is like remote evaluate
and just takes a machine name well we
have imagined it but it is
there are there are
a fair bit of engineering would be
required to make that work it's not a
simple thing because then we have to
have a scheduler that runs on that
on that machine it is what happens if
you say remote
submit and what you give is the machine
id
is a batch submission environment
is that great well wait that's what it
is right now
that's what what is well remote remote
the only extant remote submit is the
existing name of what we are going to
change to
back submit or batch or remote batch
submit
and remote the syntax for remote submit
is you give it
a remote submission i understand i
understand but i'm saying that that
you know remote evaluate conceptually
could have one of these except it will
come back and say no you can't do that
because this has to be an asynchronous
thing or or maybe it does it maybe it
just
takes it and it does it as a blocking
thing
and you might wait for 15 minutes
i think that i think that that makes
sense in theory it would be up to roman
as to whether that totally breaks other
assumptions on how remote evaluate is
supposed to work but that would just be
no i mean remote evaluate is pretty open
i mean
the the common thread is that it blocks
and until the thing is here and
so that wouldn't be completely crazy i
mean it would be a simple up value
right i mean you you could have up
values for
any kind of environments that allow you
to
submit to start something and wait until
it finishes and get the result back
yes that's entirely possible right now
there are also
options of remote submit which aren't
are there aren't options of remote
evaluate
i'm not sure how we'd want to handle
that
fine and i mean there is cloud there's
cloud submit which could also i mean
that actually makes a lot of sense to be
able to say remote evaluate
and give as argument a cloud a cloud
base
fine so conceptually there's nothing
that
i mean it should be pretty easy to i
mean that the overlap of functionality
is very small but it's just a
convenient way of saying remote evaluate
of some environment
comma expression and that environment
will they know what to do
i mean okay so then with that in mind
it seems to me that in the future we
should have a remote submit that can
take an arbitrary environment
right now we only have the one case of
batch environments
what that's making me think is that
again
we should defensively name it right now
remote batch submit
with the idea that in the future we will
have a general remote submit
and that the remote batch submit will
become a special case
that will largely be run by people
just changing their submission
environment
so that as somebody was asking on the
live stream here it becomes easy
to just say okay i'm going to say remote
you know i can actually just have a list
of possible places
that i can remote evaluate our cloud
some machine of yours aws
azure whatever else and i just have to
pick that first argument
to decide what to do okay i agree with
that on the basis
uh that uh i'm i would like to keep my
code base which is currently called
remote submit
uh uh dedicated to batch submission it
would it would be too confusing to
to have to later introduce um other
things into it that are not that
submission and
and what makes the most sense uh for uh
for having that happen is to rename it
to
something more specific like remote
batch submit and keep remote submit open
for
for that's what i think we should do and
i think we should have a longer term
plan that we're going to have a remote
submit of which remote batch submit
becomes a special case
let me make sure i understand the
long-term plan are you suggesting that
we have remote evaluate
and remote submit the sort of grand
functions that
if if given a certain type of
environment like a batch submission
environment or something
would then do the bash thing and the
difference is that but
in remote submit mode evaluate blocks
and remote submit
returns a task object yep
that's the idea okay that sounds
reasonable
now by the way remote batch submit is
not returning a task object is it
correct it's returning a a remote a
remote remote
right now a remote job object it will
become i don't know
batch java right so remote job object is
the analog
of a a cloud submit of a scheduled task
returning a task object wrapped in a
cloud object wrapping a cloud object
so one could imagine the future that the
remote submit
of one of these things returns a task
object that wraps a remote job object
yes i think that sounds good
okay so then the raw the raw version
is then remote batch submit and it
returns
the raw remote batch
job object
and in the future
that would get wrapped
right um
okay okay so fine so let's let's keep
going here so now
i want to say i want to say why i like
this idea i like this idea because it
allows uh remote submit and remote java
object
et cetera again whatever they get called
i'm just using the names that i know
um to uh to have interfaces that are
that
are relatively complex and make sense
and have have things that are specific
to them while while
um having this idea in the future of of
having a task object that wraps a remote
job object
um and and provides a simplified uh
consistent
uh interface it means that i don't have
to i don't have to
um artificially simplify the the uh
job object that job object interface to
make it fit into the existing
exhaust and so people who just want to
do simple things will use the higher
level wrapper
people who want to fill in all the
details will use the lower level thing
it's exactly the same
as external evaluate where most people
just say external evaluative you know
python comma whatever but if they want
to they can use
external evaluate of the um
what is it called x what is what is the
first argument called external
obsession something external session
object yeah protection
right um and you know and get much more
detailed and say which instance of which
of which version etc etc etc but most of
the time people don't care
okay let's keep going here all right so
now
so have we written down the names let's
just
exactly answer it okay so what we're
saying is
remote batch submit here
remote batch i'm not that keen on that
name
i i don't think there's a there's a
better option because can they have to
have map and you have to have i have to
have map
i agree the thing that's weird is we
don't
have a parallel map submit
well because we don't re parallel submit
is something that it really is quite
different
uh from any other submission thing it's
more of a roaming correction if i'm
wrong i think it's more of a queuing
system
than uh by submit which implies
asynchronous
uh uh action well i mean it's both i
mean the
point is that the queuing system works
because parallel
parallel jobs are
are asynchronous i'm sorry does somebody
know if i have a
section here already for this
i think you do because we've saved
something in the last
i have an aws link section here
not sure that's the right place for this
remote submit
no r's oh yes no
um
trapped what should i call this um
well i'm gonna put it under aws link
okay okay that's not that's not not a uh
not a good categorization in the long
run okay so
can you move that to something can you
move that aws link thing and the other
thing and both of these
to something called uh let's cut say
um remote computation okay
we'll do because ada the thing that it
exists that is called aws link is
completely separate from anything that
we're discussing here okay
right remote batch job whoops remote
batch job object
i i just i want to ask roman though with
with parallel submit
is is it possible to have a scenario
where the main
the main kernel is not blocking but
parallel kernels are doing some
computation
can that state exist well i mean they
will
once something has been submitted then
these kernels will run
and until their jobs are done but then
they will become
idle until you trigger another round
but they don't are they are the kernels
ever running when you're not doing
weight all
well as long as there's something to do
yes i mean
you see even the parallel submit itself
will trigger
a queue run and so okay parallel itself
will
will start evaluate okay and then what
is why is weight why is it called weight
or oh oh so okay of course is this right
if you do
okay is this right if you do parallel
submit and your evaluation on your
parallel kernel starts
and then it finishes and then you do
wait all it will return immediately
yes if they're all finished yes okay
that makes sense
thank you um
okay let's move on here okay do we need
the word submission in here
uh
i think so because it's
it is the thing that it is
okay i'm not i'm not certain we can
discuss it but
um well let's see what it is in more
detail when we get to that documentation
okay sure okay remote batch jobs
just returns the list of remote batch
job objects exactly
okay so
this is
right so these um i'd like i'd like your
any comments on the structure because i
want to
be able to give this to the docs team
because i think they have to
manual work is required to implement a
new uh type
new reference type so this is these
pages are intended to document the
things that are specific to
individual providers
yeah i mean this is this is going to be
similar to what we have for blockchains
for example
yes
you know you should just have used the
um function repository
uh mechanism for creating tables and
things
it's there's some what's how's that
different i mean it's just this isn't
supposed to be stopped
and so on oh well this is just a this is
just content this has nothing this is no
styling or layout
that that will happen when it's actually
a proper direct page right now it's just
a plain notebook
so what is the category remote batch
submission exactly yes
why does the word submission in there
remote batch
well there has to be a verb right okay
well submit submission makes it clear
that it's asynchronous
i mean that i sure i mean i don't know
maybe batch also
makes it clear that it's asynchronous um
i just think submission provider
suggests that they're providing the
submission mechanism
rather than that they're providing the
mechanism that you submit to
well they are providing the submission
mechanism for certain parts of that
phrase
is the mechanism with which you submit
mechanism
but they're also providing the mechanism
that actually does the computation
yeah sure
you know but that raises the question
whether this is a submission environment
or a computation environment computation
environment i want to avoid because
there is a specific thing on aws called
a compute environment which is related
to to all of this uh but it is not it's
not right we don't represent it in the
wolf of language language so that
specific phrasing
i want to avoid so wait a minute is this
thing here
the submission infrastructure or is it
the actual environment that's running
things
it is a it is a data structure it is
that represents
bits of data that remote submit needs to
be able to submit a job it
uses this data it tells it where to
submit
the job but but that does that include
you've got a 96 cpu gpu enabled
computer and things no that's on a
that's on a there's no length there's no
uh technical reason that couldn't be the
case but i've chose to
put things that i think people want to
choose on the job level
as options to remote submit and then
things that i think people will
want to keep the same across multiple
jobs in the uh
okay so then the correct term is
submission environment
i think that the name of this category
should be
batch computation environment the name
of this cat these category pages
that's what i would suggest okay
why why why are you okay with me i i
don't object to that but i'm just
curious why are you okay with omitting
remote in that in that case since we're
using remote everything else
because it's obvious it's remote it's
just like when we say
and now i'm going to prove myself wrong
but i'm pretty sure when we have
the documentation for python for example
um
that we don't say
okay so i'm i'm proving myself wrong
here well it has to say
external evaluation system wouldn't make
any sense
that would be totally ambiguous i think
it's like
we don't say for an import format we
don't say that it
is i
okay i admit this probably is better as
a remote batch computation provider
i mean it's just we will i doubt we will
ever have a
a a batch computation provider that is
not a remote batch computation provider
uh and if we do then it would only be
there could only be one which is local
i'm just thinking of
i'm i'm thinking of uh you know for
microsoft employees using azure
um is it a remote batch computation
provider
or is it i it's very confusing it's
remote to us
right i mean for micro it's remote to
everybody because it's in some data
center somewhere where there are just a
couple technicians
i mean on a physical level
it is it is almost always remote
suggestion from alexander on a live
stream to use the word processing
instead of computation
we don't really say processing anywhere
yeah we don't really anymore
it's not even referring to well we don't
even processing that word i don't think
we use we have processes
but um yeah i don't know whether we
should have the word remote here
let's let's um um
okay let's take are you okay with the
structure of those of those pages
so like the headings yeah i think so i
think so i mean i
i'm not as familiar with my only issue
with those pages would be
you know i'm a practical person i want
to use this
boy i mean this is so complicated my
gosh
what what part is complicated what part
are you looking at and saying it's
complicated
well just the length of stuff that's
here so i mean my question would be
for me okay i got a piece of code i want
to run it
how much of this do i have to read you
ha
you have to read if this is your very
first time you have to read
that workflow which does not exist uh
under setup i
i i plan to have a workflow first for
each work uh
remote submission provider which details
the one-time setup steps that you need
to do
so it's like give give them my credit
card number and
well not not ex not exactly that because
we can link to something that says how
to
set up an aws account if you don't have
an aws account but even if you already
have an aws account you have to
configure some infrastructure
on aws and i will make that as as
seamless and as automatic as i possibly
can
but there will be some some manual
elements because there are always some
manual elements and it's important to
make people
make manual choices when those choices
affect how much money they're going to
spend i think um so once once that is
set up
uh you you can skip all of those
sections you can go down to example and
drop your
drop your code in there well you have to
construct that remote submission
environment object which i will i'll try
to have
the the configuration process just
output one of those
um and you can you can you can store it
somewhere you can put it in that
dollar default remote submission
environment so it's your it's your
default okay so you should say that
somewhere here in the example you should
maybe even the
first example you should just say paste
in from wherever
because otherwise somebody will look at
this and they'll say oh my god where are
they they'll think they'll think they
can use that
right um okay but yeah that's fair
um so then you have that thing and then
you can right ahead
you can go do the the second line which
is remote submit your code
that environment okay except you want to
flip the order of the arguments
right i did i didn't write i didn't flip
them yet because i wanted to just get
the final
final approval on that because that also
i i agree with flipping the order
well you were that you were the only one
who you were the one who suggested that
so you
um but uh but yes okay flipping the
order and
just to be clear for roman's uh benefit
do you also want to flip the order from
remote evaluate because remote evaluate
has
i believe the same expression machine
machine post name um
yeah i think that's that's necessary i
mean i i don't
yeah i agree i mean the problem is that
in remote
uh remote evaluate it makes a certain
amount of sense to have a default
machine and so it's it's always a bit
strange when the second argument i mean
the first argument is obviously
i think that's that's that's that's
perfectly fine yes okay
but mutual evaluator is not yet in the
system right
it's it's in the prototype okay fine
okay so we can flip that
yes good let's do it okay okay
um all right option
okay so remote
remote batch map submit
environment function list i agree
and the environment can be omitted if
you have a default environment to say
yes because you can't admit the other
arguments here and similarly remote
batch submit the environment can be
uh omitted yes absolutely brian is
asking what happens to echo on a remote
patch job
uh echo will get uh will get sent to the
standard out uh log if you ever
if you try echo in a standalone kernel
uh you'll see it it has a
special appearance it actually it's
actually not that great because if you
you know that you can have a tag in echo
which is
the second argument um if you use a tag
it does not put a space between the tag
and the body um and that's that's
actually probably a bug that i should
that i should file but echo does have a
special appearance
in a standalone kernel that's distinct
from print and it will show up that way
um what is this i've not seen that that
um
that greeting will from desktop kernel
it's i think that's always been there
just
different because i guess this has been
a wolf and desktop installation instead
of mathematica
but i think that's always been there i
mean well i mean for as long as
as long as i can remember um which isn't
that long
so you get those those two uh arrows uh
echo label you're saying no no just echo
of
like two comma uh some string
right it doesn't that's terrible that's
a bug
yeah and is it obvious that we shouldn't
put the hello before the
before the greater than greater than i
think that would that would make sense
to put it before but doesn't it come
before in the in the dust and the
in the uh no no it comes after i think
but it's it's styled differently
it's styled like the uh the greater the
greater than
maybe we should flip it in both cases by
the way that doesn't have the right
spacing
either well it's better than no space
i know but this looks stupid there's a
big place here
and then there's i think it's just the
wrong way around
okay i i personally prefer how it is
right now in the in the front end
um but not in the economy who deals with
this who's dealing with this
anybody know carly go track down who's
dealing with this
okay we'll do and and i would make this
weak suggestion that we put the tag
before the greater than greater than but
that may not be supportable for other
reasons
i think the greater than greater than
has to be first to
so we can clearly see what things coming
from echo you know and not from
yeah that's that's true and i i would i
would also keep it that way in the
sandal
all right okay fine fine fine fine then
it's just a bug here
um although it's a pity that there's no
delimiter at the end of that and the
standalone kernel
possibly another greater than greater
than to indicate the end of that styling
or something
i'm not sure or colon or something
perhaps okay um
okay so i'd like to see how you actually
get to that log
okay if you uh scroll down to the demos
section and it's saying in 12.2 it's
fixed that there is a space oh wonderful
okay say that again demos uh yeah down
to demos and the remote submit section
that would look absolutely
okay okay so this is our environment
boy that's a horrifying
piece of infrastructural gunk well it
has to exist because people
need all of that data i understand that
but ultimately there's infrastructural
gunk
yeah that's true our goal is to hide the
infrastructural gunk
um um
so down it's a little bit more
yeah job log
i see so those two long horizontal lines
any any messages
or logs produced from within your job
code will go inside there
so is there any way to make this more
computable this job log
i i don't think so i mean it
fundamentally exists as a
as a string
i mean we could choose to tag it and
bring it in i mean if it's only going to
be consumed by our users
in our system we could add tagging
information in that string
that would allow us to reconstitute it
to something more you know
allow us to parse it as something okay
first it is what
one okay one thing one bit of
information that isn't there is
time stamps there's on aws not
necessarily the case everywhere else on
aws there is a time stamp
timestamp associated with each line uh
which i
i don't i don't show that well maybe we
should have another another thing
called uh you know job log
i would do that as like an option to the
sub value if we could
so like job log comma uh show time
stamps goes to truth
yeah we could do that but i think you
know we could say
timed job right right now this is the
least common denominator format
if a provider gives me a log it will we
will have it in at least this format
it's possible that there will be fine
but if you say time
job log then it can give a message
saying sorry this provider doesn't give
one of those
sure i think time job
why are we why don't we just have one
job log that has
times if it can be provided or not i
understand we want to have all these
extra
options for because because i could
imagine
well okay so the question is what
consumes this
i i think a human should consume that i
think the most useful scenario is well i
mean what you're going to see
okay i have no idea what you're going to
see i mean at some level are you going
to see a
virtual machine booting in this log no
no no no you'll you this you will see
this
and then between those horizontal lines
if there are any error messages or
prints or echoes
from your code that you submit they will
show up there
okay but in a perfect world this would
reconstitute itself as notebook output
but it's it's not it never existed as a
notebook
right but insofar as there is a
correspondence between
you know you could say that about the
about
you know the actual process that is the
kernel
is producing these things but they are
packaged
in such a way that in a notebook they
will show up in a nice format
that's not true try try net train
yeah here yeah in the sandlin kernel
what do i not try and just get the
example from the documentation i don't
know the syntax
well i know the syntax but i'm just i
don't know what term well there's this
there's a simple example
am i going to see the the um
just get the first one really is that is
that enough
yeah it worked it worked for me okay
oh wow
so this has no correspondence no no
no uh perfect no no no direct
correspondence to what you'd see in a
notebook it it represents the same thing
that you get from that dynamic
yes it's very useful and it's it's uh
the person had
asked earlier about about uh using using
that train with remote submit this is
this is the the data that the live data
that you'd be able to get
but there's no i can't think of any
useful way to convert this into a
notebook at least not any way that would
look
like actually here's a suggestion from
sw on the live stream
what if there is a job log
event series okay
which which would actually be the um
so this would become i mean that would
be
cute which is actually the event series
it would be it would be cute but there's
very limited utility to an event an
event series with string values because
you can't do anything that you normally
i mean except
like i don't know just plotting the
times but you can't do anything you
would normally do with an
event series i think it would be better
to have like a data set with
time stamps and strings possibly
yes possibly but something to remember
is that this log could potentially
depending on how you what kind of
messages or debug output you put in this
log could be very big
and it could be too uh uh well okay
data sets should in theory be able to
handle something i think so but
okay i mean look i agree that this is
the good place to start
it's just to have this so are we are we
suggesting job log
which perhaps has time stamps added if
they're available and then job logs
i'm not suggesting about adding the
timestamps if they're available well
okay i don't know um
joblog dataset would have the timestamps
if they're involved i think
i think that's right yes i think that's
the right thing to
you know what if they're available you
should probably put them in job log
and we should probably have another
version of something called job log
messages
let's say that only gives the messages
well
messages that's that's something
different if you want messages okay if
you want messages from h
from a job that succeeded which will uh
which remember
has no has no no bearing uh whether the
your code did what you expect has no
bearing on whether the job succeeded but
the job succeeded
if it didn't crash so if the job
succeeded you can get the evaluation
messages
uh property of the job object and that
will be like
you've seen the evaluation data about
that's um there's messages and messages
text
so if you want just the messages you can
get them from that uh
which i'll note does not have time
stamps but i don't think that's really
weird
by the way sw sh on the live stream is
pointing out the timeline plot would
work
nicely on a job log event series and it
isn't completely useless because if you
if between those double lines you are
you know the only communication is from
an echo
right then you can perfectly well put
some echoes into your code and you'll be
able to see
easily what's going on and in fact
well on the timeline plot for sure you
can certainly imagine if you've got that
as look having it as a data set is fine
but then you know if you've echoed
something which is an expression
or something you know you don't know if
it's an expression or not we don't we
only know it's a string because it's
right
we only know it's a string but if you
know that you only echoed expressions
then you know you could potentially look
i suspect that we will need eventually
is something
which for example only gives you the
stuff between these two lines
right so that it is just a from your job
reporting okay and then you control the
from your job reporting
and if you put stupid stuff in there
then you'll get stupid stuff out
but if you put in just a
i mean as i have often done you know i i
put in when i run
overnight jobs i very very very often
have um
you know things that come out which
allow me to see roughly what's
what happened okay can i i i want i
would like to propose that
job log is just the stuff between the
lines job
full log is everything job log data set
is a data set of just the stuff within
the lines job
you know we're now we're adding like
half a dozen properties but job full log
data set could be
everything um that sounds like good
job full log okay job job log
and just just so we're clear i don't
think this affects anything but it is
possible to have a job that has
all uh no lines if it if if something if
a failure happened before it entered
your code
only one line or if uh if a failure
happened
in your code like it crashed while it
was running your code um
okay look anything that came from your
job
as valid output from your job shows up
in joblog
anything that is meta information like
the thing crashed
is in full log in addition to the stuff
from your job or you should just
with that instead be like job metal
well i think it should be an addition
for now
we may later realize that we only want
the um
uh the stuff outside the line okay okay
i agree but i should i should mention
you said
stuff like it crashed we don't the we
don't
particularly know um if it if it crashed
it's i actually now that i think about
it i could
i should have the functionality i should
be able to insert in a log
if the if the process itself crashed um
but right now the best that we'll have
is just whatever
uh whatever the last uh message or print
or whatever was
i think it would be nice to put in
something with a star that shows it's
coming from somewhere else
job crashed or something right yeah
right right now that's not possible but
i have some
changes i already intend to make which
will make that possible okay
so ethan was suggesting earlier
um can you add an in-notebook master
scheduling dashboard with ui
and etas and he later offered you swiss
chocolates if you do that
okay well i was going to say no but
since i heard about the swiss chocolates
i'm considering um
i mean that we would be we would be
largely reinventing what you can already
get if you go to the aws console
um i see uh i mean they don't have etas
but i it's only only in some jobs will
an eta actually be something
you know parallel map monitored which is
in the function repository i use
all the time and it has an eta and it's
quite useful
okay well i i have my dynamic status
visualization which is
it is in the same class of thing it does
not have an eta right now but
i don't think there's any reason it
couldn't um
it would be an eta this is only for uh
for
uh um uh array jobs
submitted with remote batch maps of it
which i think that's the only case in
which you can have an idea it doesn't
you can't do it for a single evaluation
um but yes i think i could have an eta
and that it would it probably wouldn't
be as accurate because it's the
timing data is not as granular as it is
this parallel map monitor knows for
every single evaluation while this only
knows for the
child jobs which are chunks of multiple
evaluations um but it would be possible
i think to add
uh an eta estimate that's a uh
sorry an eta to uh to the dynamic stage
visualization
okay so hold on the um
i i have to go to another meeting fairly
soon here so
uh there's a comment about the
importance of having beta testing
of all of this stuff and hopefully we
will be able to make it available to
testers
fairly soon is that once we've got this
naming straightened out we should be
able to make some versions available is
that true
there's uh licensing which i'm working
on and and
need to finish um but after after that's
done
i think you can end the necessary
documentation for like setting up your
own environment
that's those are the things required
right um okay
forward cloud credentials what the heck
is that
it's it's actually quite
useful it it copies your local cloud
credentials uh
into the the remote uh the remote kernel
um so you can you can do cloud things
from within that
uh that kernel oh my god that's a that
is
my gosh this is so hairy
okay okay so okay hold on one thing i
just want to say that exact wording
forward cloud credentials is an option
in the in the
parallel preferences um section of the
preferences
and it does what it sounds like forward
your uh master kernel cloud credentials
into subconscious
so i didn't invent the wording i just
invented making it an option
but but how does that work i mean does
it forward all your epc credentials does
it do a biography what does it do
it forwards whatever your credentials
are which is your your oauth token but
does it but it doesn't do it in any kind
of plain text form or does it
well it does do it it does do it in
plain text but it's always being sent
over and and
stored it sent over an encrypted link
it's stored in a private bucket in the
case of um
uh s3 i have it explicitly you cannot do
it on charity engine
uh there's no technical reason why not i
have it disabled because it's a security
risk because your code is running on
someone else's
computer and they could they could they
could get their make their way in and
get your credentials for inside there
but is that obvious that you can't have
some cryptographic
mechanism for you to it is obvious
because they they're they're controlling
the computer
fundamentally they can they can get in
if there's a cryptographic key somewhere
they can find it because again it's
running on on there
unless you had a third party verifier of
that key that is
unless unless you are simply from that
remote computer
pinging something which then picks up
your key
uh never mind it doesn't work yeah it
doesn't
um yeah wait a minute i this is a weird
concept i mean
where else haven't we needed this isn't
this
what the authentication option with
isn't this what the keychain stuff does
keychain stuff is all local yes my
keychain
stores your password to actually log
into the cloud but
say in your parallel computation so you
are locked into the cloud in your
mastercard
and now you want to do parallel evaluate
of no i guess output something which
uses an entity and it needs your cloud
credentials and so on
yes so so what would it be called
what is the name of a i've suddenly
blanked out on what's the name
that we've given for uh
something from the uh key chain what do
we call a system credential key
or system credential okay so system
credential
that's system it's your local system it
is no no
no relevance anywhere else okay does
this forward your cloud credentials for
a private cloud
yes it does but
okay it does but it won't necessarily
work if you're if your
private cloud is behind the vpn or
something then the
easy to instance unless you do network
manual network configuration you're not
going to be able to
get it but it makes it it makes it the
best effort uh
attempt to um to send all the all the
necessary questions but maybe the right
thing to describe here
is not the cloud credentials but to have
an to have the possibility of having an
association
that can give you given a given that
your code references a cloud
here's how you try to get to it
i i'm not sure i don't understand well
so i mean let's imagine
you've set cloud base to you know my
internal server.com
okay and from your code on aws
you see this piece of code and it just
says you know
cloud evaluate of my internal server.com
okay with cloudbase of my internal
server.com
wait so now you're specifying the cloud
base explicitly in
in your job code that is correct in my
job i'm specifying the cloud base
but i'm not specifying in my job
any credentials because i i already did
a cloud connect
in my local session which set up those
credentials
but in see see okay let me
back up for a second this is the
alternative
to saying cloud connect in aws
right this is the alternative this is
more secure because you're not embedding
your password
in the job code i i understand it i'm
just saying but yes yes it is the
alternative you're right
okay so so in principle
for parallel kernels how do parallel
kernels you're saying parallel kernels
already have this option
yes yes it's not it's not exposed
programmatically but it's an option in
the in the preferences the front-end
preferences
it's called forward cloud credentials
i just don't particularly like the name
because i'm i'm thinking you know
like uh forward could be of
it's not necessarily a verb um
well but i mean that's that's how
authentication
happens more and more i mean if you if
you have a
google account and then you log in
somewhere else you often have
have the option of using your google
account and
kind of i understand so what's our
general mechanism for that
i mean that's what we do with single
sign-on right that's single science i
mean that that's the whole that's
all i don't find all that stuff i don't
think that's related to what's going on
here though
um because this is all this is doing is
copying the stuff that is
already in your local session question
question if if i
also have authentication for
using a random api you know
api or something right
i might also want to forward that
information or is that not correct no
that
no i don't need to do it the only reason
i don't need to do it
is the for the cloud is because of cloud
connect because normally i would have
used cloud connect to get that
connection
wait what not to some random api you use
no no i'm saying
i'm i'm correcting myself cloud api
right what i'm saying right now i'm
correcting myself
here's what i'm saying i was thinking so
if i call an api with with url read or
something
okay yeah then i have to be responsible
for the authentication within the url
read
command basically that's actually that's
not entirely true
um i'm not it might be true for url read
i believe url execute will if it is a
cloud a will from cloud url it will
automatically inject the authenticator
okay fine but but for our cloud it does
that
now what's coming is the system services
mechanism
right which which gives you
authentication for many system services
so for example what is a system
okay so for example our satellite image
provider okay somewhere deep inside the
system
there is authentication for the
satellite image provider
okay if you want to download gazillions
of satellite images you can get
uh you know a separate account with them
which you can then pass through
our system to allow you to then download
gazillions with satellite images
okay how does this differ from a service
connection
because these are things which are
they are integrated services some of
them are deeply integrated things you
didn't know were external
okay fine that makes sense okay so
but those deeply integrated things
will allow one to like you're doing here
for the cloud
you could have a separate you could have
something which is preset
as this is my account for the satellite
image provider
now every time you use geo image it will
use that
see what i'm saying okay unlike url
execute
where normally if you're going to an
external api you have to give the
authentication right there
it's a way of pre-setting so what i'm
arguing is that this
credentials thing is there's a
generalization of this which is
forwarding system credentials
okay the system do system credentials
currently exist
no except in the form of well the only
thing they
exist in system services have
credentials
and that that mechanism does not yet
exist but the
concept of a system credential is yet
something different
it's a keychain credential right
well right now i'm only able to forward
what exists which is cloud credentials
and this was
this is this was seen at least at the
time to the most reasonable way to do
that if there is a
if you have a suggestion for designing
in anticipation of a generalization
well that's why i think i'm i'm thinking
about
um
i would just say forward credentials
and what would what does it look like is
it true or false yeah i guess
okay yeah true means forward the
credentials you have
um
okay how do we how do we make it i'm not
sure
how do we make it clear what credentials
are being forwarded because right now
it's only cloud credentials it's not
service connections it's not
anything else
like cloud credentials forwarding arrow
true or false
well okay then that's a um that's uh
that's a noun phrase and it doesn't
doesn't match with like include
definitions which is
all right okay okay okay okay i mean
it's do i forward cloud credentials or
not
yes or no
all right okay fine i agree
okay so
job input files that should probably be
that's job input files or remote job uh
remote batch job input files um not sure
which but it should it should have a
prefix to it
i think it should be remote batch job
input files
why is that an option why is that not
part of some association which has all
kinds of configuration information for
the job
in other words that's provider settings
provider settings is an association that
has
optional association that has
configuration stuff for the job but
provider settings is all of the uh
pieces of the configuration values that
are that thing has to be called rematch
remote batch job provider settings
you're right it should be um that that
is
that is uh an association of options
that are specific to a
a a submission provider job input files
will work on as many submission
providers as will support it
okay all right these options appear
inside remote batch submit right
correct so i don't see why they should
repeat the whole name there i mean they
are kind of scoped by
where they appear yeah but we've tried
to avoid that because i mean your my
screen isn't
wide enough for all of these names right
i mean
knowing you roman i'm sure you have a
very big screen but
i think i think the fact that the fact
that we currently have no plans to call
anything else a job
ever um because when whenever this back
uh remote submit comes along it will
return task objects
listen i think we should defensively
name these things if they can be
generalized later then we can generalize
them later
i think we should add all these prefixes
i know they're ugly
um so so we have just
for my uh to clarify we have remote
batch
uh oh and remote maps job input files
and then should be remote submission
provider settings or
remote job provider settings
um
oh boy
look i think we could probably get away
with remote provider settings
because i think that that will have we
may be able to reuse that option for
some other things
okay as long as um as long as we can
guarantee that it will always be an
association which i think is reasonable
it will be okay so remote batch job
input files and remote provider settings
why don't we just call it remote input
files and then we can reuse that for
lots of other things
okay sure again if we expect that it
will always be an association of
either um of strings to file names or
strings to external
storage this will be fine i mean so that
would be remote
input files and this would be remote
provider settings okay i think that
makes sense
um and now there are some limitations
with job input files that
won't necessarily be limitations for
other other uses of that don't worry
about it okay
okay um
uh can you just uh oh or if you have
something to do you want to see that's
no no but i just
okay just yeah those visualizations
again that they
will go go to design but i just want
improvement okay
that's cool but i mean i yes i mean okay
this is
what the heck is this this is a what is
this
oh this is for the for the for the array
jobs
yes each each cell is a child job of the
array boy this is complicated
it's also very helpful very useful it
sure is
yes well i mean there isn't so wait a
minute so
this question about a ui
this is more relevant the ui is relevant
for array jobs it's not so relevant for
single batch jobs is it or is it i mean
because a single batch job
it's like i'm running my turing machine
i have no idea when it will hold
right in a single a single batch job the
only the only data that you can get
during for between the time of
it hits the running stage and it hits
the succeeded or failed stage the only
data the only data that changes is the
log
and any side effects that you program
into it manually um while for a
a an array job there is there's stuff
happening between the
the uh submission of the um the whole
array job and the completion of the
or failure of the whole array job which
is that the child jobs are
are are succeeding or failing uh
as they go along
so and this does not persist to chrome
because because it is dynamic and it
requires
cloud stuff to happen it does not sorry
uh uh it requires network stuff to
happen it does not persist across uh
sessions why can't it rehydrate because
it might it might um
because it might be it might have
spawned into a session that does not
have authentication information
um but if it does have authentication
information why not let it work
it doesn't it does okay it's possible
but it the authentication
information might exist but might not be
the same it might be for a different
cloud account
sorry different aws account and then it
has to do a network request
basically i'm very i'm very wary of
having any dynamic thing that
automatically does a network request
as soon as it appears because then then
you end up with issues like if your
network's
uh down it might hang forever but
there's no security issues there
there is no there's no uh there's no no
there's no security
but but you know we have timeouts and i
i really think it should rehydrate if it
can
i mean it doesn't need to be there for
v1 but i think it should rehydrate if it
can
okay okay there's a question for brian
about illusion if there are hundreds of
entries in the array
um i mean clearly you should you should
just
get rid of the mesh if you if it gets
too big or you'll only see the mesh
i'm sure you've got it i don't think
you'll always see the
i mean i don't think you'll only see the
match if you i mean the the example how
many jobs
yeah maximum you can have on aws batch
is
ten thousand okay sorry nine thousand
nine hundred ninety nine okay but so
it's a hundred across so it's no big
deal right
okay so so the answer is there won't be
a problem just because of limitations on
aws
but you might have put into the code
something which if it gets to be a
thousand across
we have a million jobs in some future
you know
future cloud provider well it's
it's an array plot shouldn't a rape lack
do that well i guess oh it doesn't
matter okay
okay so now ethan is saying
most people don't have personal aws
infrastructure but rather have multiple
aws accounts that connect with
multi-factor
authentication into a jump host secured
vpns et cetera et cetera et cetera
do we know if that all works right there
is no
ssh never comes into play here the
submission job submission is happening
via the aws api which you can access as
long as you have
authentication information uh for your
your aws account
and your your your your credentials
that information through multi-factor
you know
stuff and so on but then you basically
copy paste that into that
uh no no it does not go into there in
fact this has changed since the last
time you saw it or rather this has been
added it's now powered by a service
connection the aws client
what is called just called aws the aws
service connection uh which on your
um if you want to try it you can you can
try it um
do the run the initialization uh there
yeah i need to go soon but
i want to just try something yeah
that'll that'll take a minute though
because it has to install
uh i'm not about a minute but um a
little little
while to install some packets
what the heck is all of this it's just
it's just installing patterns
okay but then then what do i do that
then so whatever then you'll run that
that next bit there that's remote
submission environment object
and since it's the first time you're
doing it um it will pop up a service
connection
uh dialogue
okay so now i run this
oh exciting
okay so you can check check the
automatic and manual just so you you can
see the difference
with automatic you specify a profile
name um
uh with uh which is a there's a
well-defined location that you can put a
file
in your your home directory that lists
potentially multiple
sets of credentials
thank you and then for manual you you're
specifying those your credentials
uh access can you get this stuff from
your system keychain
um well you can't get it from the system
keychain because no
no no one stores it there like the aws
cli doesn't use the keychain
uh could we put it in the in the system
keychain uh yes
that's really dependent on the the
larger service connection uh system
supporting the keychain which it doesn't
right now because it predates it
it supported the key chain
you could potentially store the stuff in
your key chain and not have to fill it
in
right um yes correct well it also it
also stores it um
using the existing mechanism for saving
service connections which is
some combination of a local file
somewhere and also some cloud thing that
i don't i don't really know how
to spend commenting i'm not sure what
the right
but refers to switch based on
environment variables based on the aws
command line
credentials right you can you cannot it
does not look at the environment
variable
um it probably should um
so yes if uh and i don't think there's
any reason
um it couldn't it couldn't do that
um look at what the environment will be
it's like yes it's something like aws
underscore profile
um that's what the the aws cli will look
at that
is a name what is that a name
that is in a uh uh in your uh tilled
slash dot aws slash
credentials uh file um so you can have
the the default one that says there is
default it's a it should
you right now you have to type default
in that's a bug that has to do with
the word yes you have to type that in
um and that and that will uh it's a bug
that
it doesn't use that use that by default
but um so i think
so it will it uses your credentials that
are in that file uh roger has has set
those up for you so
oh so so so i can actually do this yes
should be able to
so you mean i can actually run a job on
aws that's exciting
submitting to provider cool
so you can check the status that should
um i think i have the
okay so if i say job evaluation data it
says not missing not available
right yeah it should say missing job not
or something it should actually it is i
i intend to
have it be missing not available and
then the second argument is
status goes to whatever the current job
status is okay it would say
status or job status perhaps goes to
running so
um i i i intend to have that in there
this is very cool how long is it going
to take um
about a minute and a half because it
looks like it's not using a
um a warm instance there are a couple
different states that it can be in that
affect how long
a job a job takes for them but i'm i'm
watching it on my end and it's still in
the starting
state
okay but so
i see so so it didn't have a warm
instance because
i haven't provisioned those instances or
because what
well actually it did have a it did have
a warm instance because i configured it
before this meeting to have a
warm in to keep an instance running but
i think it doesn't have the um
the uh image of the container image
cached on that instance
so if we can if the best case scenario
um
you there's uh in the best case scenario
on aws it's about 10 or 15 seconds
before it launches
between remote submit you you evaluating
that and it actually launching into your
job code on the instance so so
let me just ask you a really practical
question because i might actually use
this today
i'd like to um the uh the instance you
have configured for me is it is it a
reasonably juicy machine well it uses it
uses however many
um the cpus you request right now you
only requested one because that's the
default but you can set
in the provider settings option you can
say vcpu count goes to any integer from
one to 96
um and it will it will it will launch an
instance based on uh based on that
so when i say so you're saying if i said
remote submit here
and i would just say instead of that i
would say remote submit
and then i would say provider settings
arrow association yep
uh and then vcpu count string what's
vcpu
virtual cpu okay that's standard
terminology
um okay so if i say 96
then right and yes and your job is done
by the way
okay
okay
and i suspect if you submit a job again
if you submit that same one again it
will it will finish
up much quicker
all right that's impressed me wait on
the way down hold on how many of you
tell me how many vcps you you're going
to use because right now the the
instance it's running only at 16.
i'm going to use let's i'll use i'll use
16.
okay that should work okay so now what i
want to say
is parallel
table
just you could say 96 it would just take
like six minutes because it has to
start launch up the new installation
right
right it's just the configuration that
i've set up is
i just have shortcuts on the aws side
then i've got a new job there hey
but i don't i didn't call that let me
call that job two
and it's it started running okay so hold
on let me look at job one
the job log of job one oh i see it had
to make a request to get that job log
yes okay
um his second job is done now
then but it's if i say job two
cool asaurus okay so so now here
just for fun i want to do
that's going to be the same uh because
it's it's only running on one machine
i understand okay okay let me let me
just let me just um
okay so then eventually i'm gonna have
job three so let's look at job two job
log
okay not very excited why did it say
launching oh i see
that was a message from my
it's effectively from your code because
it happened it happened after it started
your code and before your code finished
um and job3 is done now by the way
okay so now let's say job3
cool cool really random parallel
very nice yeah i'm not lying to you runs
in parallel
that's very nice okay so
um one thing here that would really hang
me up if i
that is a we're we are going to need to
tag these things
because if i had code that had an echo
in it but then it had this launching
kernels thing and i have parsing code
that deals with this
it's just going to go bonkers if if you
really want structured data from your
job code you should be gathering that
yourself
okay it's an interesting claim okay um
okay it's like new progress monitor
unification you should think about
having unified gui
to make yes to make
i mean we just don't have that many
logging
things here i mean we that is another
it's a good project to have some kind of
unified logging framework
we don't have that yet okay ethan is
saying the
job object should have a hyperlink to
print the progress panel
just like inserting a new cell or wait
what's the progress panel
set the dynamic status visualization
which is only only exists for
uh array jobs what about going to what
about going to your amazon
whatever you're looking at jesse why
doesn't this remote job object have a
link to that thing
uh right the thing that i'm looking at
is is just a generic
dashboard it's not specific to that job
it's just
so it doesn't have a deep linking url
that will pull up the dashboard for that
job
uh there is a dashboard for that job but
it's actually less
useful than the main one i'm putting in
the rocket chat channel just so you can
see what i'm looking at
can i pull this up on the on the main
screen you're welcome too
so i'm what i was just looking at is the
first row of that job cues list
that shows me the number of jobs in each
state
and now i can also show you what an
individual jobs thing looks like which
is
i find that is useful
so if you can deep link to this that
would be a useful thing to have
this is not a deep link because it
doesn't have the job thing and
it's just it's the url is like whatever
but even just having a link to your
generic
you know how to see what's going on
on
okay i think i think that that makes
sense
um
okay
okay oh boy i am just my
um
um
oh i see ethan is saying the progress
panel doesn't exist yet
right but that's a separate thing to
have a link in that all right listen i
think we've we've
this is really nice i mean this really
yeah this is very cool
um very cool in fact i'm going to use it
today
so let's hope that my amazon account is
appropriately fueled okay yeah look
let me know so i can set the uh the max
number of vcpus appropriately okay well
i'm don't don't waste
money having them i won't i won't okay
all right good work
okay i think we're pretty much done here
um
let's uh let's get this out um
oh ethan is saying a suggestion for
making a panel for pollen collecting
console print instead of many cell
prints i agree that that's a useful
thing
we should can we get that on the ild
agenda logging framework
that collects cell prints and things
i'll let them know
okay great stuff guys all right okay
will you send this notebook to me
because it has the name changes
carla can send it she's about to rename
it yes
okay thanks okay could you send me mail
telling me where you put it
when it's moved yes okay
thanks guys good stuff and thank you
folks on the live stream very useful
comments
much appreciated all right okay
bye